[Music]
[Music]
a very warm welcome to all of you six
months after the outbreak of the
pandemic the corona virus is still
spreading around the globe it is
threatening people's lives and
livelihoods and we all know that we can
only defeat it when the world has a
vaccine this must be our main focus the
world needs to unite so that the virus
can be defeated once and for all today
we are launching a new campaign called
global goal is unite for our future
during the next month until June 27th
more people will make their voices heard
calling on everyone to contribute to our
common fight against coronavirus and
then on June 27th I will host the final
pledging summit where businesses
foundations and citizens will have the
opportunity to join forces with public
donors the money that we will raise will
finance testing programs treatments and
vaccines for countries everywhere in the
world and for everyone who needs them
this is the only way to overcome this
pandemic and to avoid another we must
take charge of our shared future for the
good of our planet and for our fellow
global citizens
indeed restarting our economy can only
truly happen once we've made tests
treatments and vaccines available to
everyone and everywhere for those who
need them so today it is our great
pleasure to announce global goal unite
for our future the next step to continue
to raise the billions needed to achieve
this outcome we must use this moment of
unity to move forward as a global
community we'll be encouraging the
millions of global citizens engage in
our movement every month to support this
campaign
[Music]
there is good news about the progress in
science developing manufacturing and
distributing those tools to everybody
who needs them Bloomberg philanthropies
is working with the World Health
Organization as you both touched on
people around the world desperate to
return to work school and see their
loved ones it's an honor to be here
asking everyone watching to take action
and support the global goal unite for
our future campaign thank you so much to
all of you for your support of this
vital campaign thank you and see you on
June 27th
you